Carnegie Mellon's writing program based
in the Dietrich college of humanities
and Social Sciences is justly renowned
for the range and depth of its offerings
and for the caliber of students it
attracts one of the reasons for that
success is surely our next speaker poet
and instructor and creative writing the
Thomas stock and Baker professor of
English Jim Daniels professor Daniels
has been on the faculty since 1981 and
as over the course of his writing career
published more than 30 books of poetry
including the book birthmarks released
in 2013 his poems have been selected for
celebration in anthologies by everyone
ranging from the Library of Congress to
garrison keillor we are delighted that
he is here today to read a poem
specially commissioned for dr. Suresh is
inauguration please welcome professor
Jim Daniels
rivers a river cannot turn around in the
face of mountains soldiers borders
denial we look back but we can't go back
the past streams behind us in a river
goes where it needs to go a river
carries on a river curls and bends when
a river changes path it changes forever
and we are transformed having crossed
the maps lines having crossed the books
borders trusting the hearts familiar
rhythm the heart is our guide the heart
that contains all numbers solutions
problems the heart is our River to the
silent guide in search of peace no
matter how we connect the Stars the
river accepts all other rivers rivers
that feed it make it stronger one River
two rivers more do not watch from the
shore anchored unchanged the earth is
moving we cannot stand still the river
says come on in the water's fine the
river is lying just a little it's rough
rocky Rapids can pull us under we hold
on tight hand grasping hand here where
two rivers make one we create islands of
discovery bridges of innovation here
where ideas meet unite and carry on the
river sings a song of change an
invitation to dance together here in
this room of pomp and plenty the dazzle
of a new source let us all close our
eyes and imagine we are on a river at
night together and alone listen to the
sound of knowledge and change it never
sleeps it crosses borders it finds its
way
you